[Música]
[Aplausos]
uma emanação do que somos terra é o meu
corpo
água meu sangue
o ar que eu respiro o meu alento
fogo meu espírito
mt tem que ter meu primeiro amor rebata
uma zona azul e branco ac foi campeã e
algum baliza num ritmo muito vento
werley tt1 de chiba cabe falar até que
aquele é um rato ele é um golo uma amiga
da vítima feito via boleto de chiba a
poeta bota kamba diami 12 jorge banda
jammil o aterramento como última can
make mochi que nem o a curva lá que nem
o kid o que diria cheto andou demonstrou
quando acabou a pequena que a mochila
chila itu em outubro de 1979 os genes x
y e uniram se em processo de fecundação
na terceira semana o ovo formado inicia
o processo de divisão celular novo meses
depois mas já ainda monich cabanha
[Aplausos]
minha mãe faz parte de uma linhagem
tradicionalista ícone bem meu pai e uma
diante de malanje baixa de cassanje
intelectuais dentro de mim
tenho duas memórias genéticas de duas
raízes e duas memórias sensoriais e duas
águas e duas memórias emocionais de duas
almas
cresci no ambiente familiar onde desde
cedo aprendi a lidar com as coisas do
dia a dia o presidente do menino
no meu bairro do rangel
todos os dias às seis da manhã a tocava
o sino da igreja nossa senhora de fátima
e ajudar vamos acordar o amanhecer e as
18 horas
o entardecer era melódico e eu ia
crescendo estatura conhecimento e
espírito vários tipos de expressão
artística e cultural sempre estiveram
presente no seio familiar
na literatura o livro do meu pai
espalhado por causa de vários temas
o máximo das minhas irmãs e adoração e
dar uma explicação na biblioteca linda
band no teatro música e à poesia sempre
esteve presente através do meu irmão
mais velho como levava viajar o mundo
explorar na leitura e na poesia nas
artes plásticas através do meu primo que
colocava os quadros que coloriram as
paredes de casa também a literatura oral
sempre esteve presente em casa com a voz
doce da minha mãe e muitas das vezes nos
seus carros das máquinas e cânticos e
outras vezes na voz emissor sus da minha
avó e sempre quer esticar o braço para
fazer a curva do abraço eu ficava
encantado com as tatuagens ondas em seu
braço
só os enfeites na areia tatuados em perl
servem para contar a história
fazem parte da cultura angolana uma
maneira
de compartilhar conhecimento de uma
geração a outra
ela contava nós ouvíamos nós ouvíamos e
ela contava só foi ter com deus e quando
chegou perante deus
delgado disse então mastigá lo e vêm ter
comigo amanhã de manhã e os ou dormiu no
dia seguinte a cantora tocou o solo
levantou se jogado muito bem ouvir
cantar o galo sendo a fim de vencer
comigo todos os dias por isso eu sou
viajar pelo mundo e aparece todos os
dias q vais embora militar de ser
arranjado também à lua foi visitar deus
não achei a sensual tomás pegava e vêm
ter comigo amanhã de manhã ea lua foi no
dia seguinte que nené que o suco
levantou-se não achei a sensual condado
com baixo dos braços muito bem no teu
caso vem ter comigo de 28 e 28 dias
por isso é que a lua parece não achei a
sensual de 28 e 28 dias
e vais embora nova língua e crescente
também o homem também o homem que isto
ia ser deus
andou andou pés na terra assim no chão
andou aqui chegou perante deus deus de
ralos de desvio ou mais pegado e vêm ter
comigo amanhã de manhã bem cedo e homem
foi à noite o homem estava cheio de fome
e com frio acendeu o fogo matou o galo
contra o pescoço depenou eu cozinho o
mel
lagos o gol e os outros lá meus dedos e
guardam metade para o dia seguinte com a
marquesa
tema que zuma queso o sol já brilhava
imperioso quando finalmente o homem
acordou atrasada e aflito lavou a cara
com água o meu rosto do garoto sobrava e
apresentou se perante deus
não ouvi cantar o garoto dele
o homem ficou cheio de medo e sem ar ea
fome eo comigo responde pela maior parte
da caminhada está bem
o galera tem uma taxa também o sonho da
lua também não dá lo mas não mataram
sendo assim viveram mas tudo com uma
taxa que o galo morrerás como ele e
quando morrer virada que apresentar
novamente e assim ainda hoje o sol ea
lua continua a viver sobre imperioso ao
meio-dia transforma e viaja não está a
descer laranjado ea lua numa cheia
sensual aparece de 28 e 28 dias
o homem do futuro tudo o que nós temos
vivemos e morremos mas durante nossas
vidas
durante a nossa vida nós podemos criar
criar e recriar com os olhos secos ou
molhados e assim fiz um caminho e o
caminho fez em mim
em 96 vi na televisão pela primeira vez
uma apresentação de capoeira no programa
conversas no quintal do dionísio rocha
onde entrevistava um mestre de capoeira
mês camisa foi amor à primeira vista
decidi então começar a treinar e fazer
parte do grupo e mais fundo em 99 minha
família imigrou para portugal onde dei
continuidade da prática
alguns anos depois por brasil para o
intercâmbio cultural também
quando decidir onde tudo começou
foi com o intuito de ajudar a dinamizar
a capoeira e nosso território nacional
não vai para além do desporto
apresentado há também com arte
e expressão intervenção celso cultural
mochi a do tatu a natan 5 em conjunto
com os amigos criamos o projeto e cinco
ex abadá projeto 5 é um trabalho a morte
fé fé onde direcionar o foco onde
ensinamos a energia trabalho é usar essa
energia focada quer construir a vida no
universo
amor harmonia tudo é energia que
sustenta tudo aberto trabalho uma
vertente diferente um responsabilidade
social
damos em todo o território nacional a
custo zero os trabalhos sociais onde
fizemos campanhas de doação de sangue
sobre o hiv sida e etc
2 retire ecológico etapa encontro com a
natureza
3 refúgio do médico
a valorização do méxico como transmissor
de sabedoria e vivência
temos o méxico almoço um grande tocador
de hyogo centro cultural mestre que
tuschi lugar do gênero também do umbu
ela acabou por fazer um trabalho
maravilhoso que padronizou os top's
vários ritmos tradicionais num os
mestres alberto maurício e ernesto do
cunene mês camisa do brasileiro o
desgaste emocional da capoeira angola
resgate das raízes anglas da poeira
todos nós ouvimos falar sobre kaká porém
angolana sim o nosso objetivo aqui
estudar lá da patos e sociológica e
antropológica e filosófica e padronizar
isso da paralisação dela a báscula que é
uma luta de agarramento feita no litoral
de luanda não é somente na ilha de
luanda
temos aqui uma imagem de ilustração
feita do jornal de angola tpa e jornal
de angola feita pelo horário mesquita
na verdade a súmula é a arte marcial que
boa é a queda é um ato de cair nas suas
muitas vezes não sabem e têm existem
vários tipos de queda vários tipos de
cuba cuba em golo
rolou da zebra que um golo é golo é a
arte marcial um golo ea zebra é a arte
marcial inspirada na zebra e também um
saco uma fuma
temos algumas imagens a ida de pesquisa
que fizemos em local no cunene um copy
com os mestres é uma luta pessoas o ps
um chute e uma cabeçada
nem os maus em queda a única queda tem
só as rasteiras bomba angula é o box de
mauá aberta influencia e inspirada no
boi boi mais forte que a pessoa que
vende na roda e faça o desafio quem
quiser pode entrar e etapas chapadas
ritmos e movimentos angolanos
eu estudo dos instrumentos tradicionais
angolanos temos algumas a sua
classificação jogou mas só lembrando
fones cordofones que tem vários nomes
também aqui na capa é conhecido como
berimbau
mas chamamos de chicomba urucum que sai
de marimba e há preocupação também nossa
é com as danças tradicionais angolanas
devemos encontrar com um um triângulo
que é voz instrumento em movimento entre
ritmos blues onde tem a voz é um
instrumento onde tem o instrumento tem
um movimento
sendo assim sentimos a necessidade de
criar algo para eu poder fazer
apresentações e performances
daí nasce e atacá la canya e ela cai há
na verdade um projeto de intercâmbio
para aceder à nossa cultura angolana
houve muita vida a dizer ea comenda fish
ea achamos que calam sagrado evento
muito mais longe de guerrilheiros ea
caixa ou bandas guerrilheiros jogas a
palavra e a kalayar era usada os anos 50
e 60 pelos conjuntos de música uma
maneira de soltar o hino da liberdade
para a luta de libertação caia os amigos
como movimentos durante muito tempo e
abraçavam se diziam caía caia vibração
positiva e aquela ganhar é um conjunto
genes é uma celebração da africanidade
na ausência do personagem
o ausente se faz presente através do
verbo antes de tudo era o verbo eo verbo
era fazer
vieram me dizer que eu não me amas
vieram me dizer que não me queres jerome
dizer que a empresa saia rasgada e
tatiana sá prostituir para me alimentar
sim vieram me dizer vieram me dizer que
têm os filhos de várias cores
sim vieram me dizer
mesmo assim eu te amo em angola mel pai
[Música]
ela não me delegaram unimar bomdia mel
um assumir o meu debatemos pensamento
religioso mesmo que eu comer o que
passei e sei que eu não posso falar
o livro eu ligo última do povo de
andorra la roche mama do povo de âmbar
angola aea
[Música]
ei
belluschi mal angola' e
[Música]
[Aplausos]
a mãe foi dada na manhã do domingo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
o gol levantou dúvidas quanto ao tamanho
de sua vida foi muito rápida na marinha
grande
um banho na marina de ipad já não dava
garantias
[Música]
[Aplausos]
kangamba que essa não vai passar também
passando de quilombos um beijo cá a
maneira com que o acusado é minha bater
dividir o angaturama mg6 bater dividir o
âmbito lebid g
[Aplausos]
o espírito não dorme espírito descansa
guerreiro joga é forjado com sorensen de
mérito em comunicações tem bombo vencer
não é um estado constante vencer em um
estado um montante a transparência
transcedência dentro da imanência
imanência dentro da tendência ea casa
cai a bater bater e matando a saudade de
lá na paraíba lula obrigado
[Aplausos]